in grand rapids michigan the federal
trial of four militia members charged in
what prosecutors said was a plot to
kidnap michigan governor gretchen
whitmer ended in two acquittals and a
hung jury for two others adriana diaz
reports on this significant defeat for
the federal government in a case that
was a centerpiece of their heavy focus
on domestic terrorism
prosecutors failed to convince the
entire jury that the men were guilty
brandon caserta and dan harris the only
defendant to take the stand were found
not guilty the jury was deadlocked on
all counts for adam fox and barry croft
jr prosecutors painted them as the
ringleaders hell bent on enacting a
second civil war but the defense said
the real masterminds were fbi informants
who they say encouraged the kidnapping
conversations i think what the fbi did
is unconscionable and i think the jury
just sent them a message loud and clear
that these tactics are not going to be
you know
we're not going to condone what they've
done here the government's kidnapping
and weapons charges centered around an
alleged plan to grab governor gretchen
whitmer from her vacation home strand
her on a boat on lake michigan and blow
up a nearby bridge to impede law
enforcement some of the men met at open
carry protests at the state capitol in
2020 rallying against michigan's covet
19 restrictions they spent much of the
summer of 2020 complaining training with
guns and drinking and smoking alongside
the confidential informants
those meetings resulted in thousands of
hours of video and audio evidence
including when croft declared a team
should be ready for a precise quick grab
whitmer whitmer michigan whitmer
at trial the defense said the case was
smoke and mirrors created by those paid
informants who befriended the defendants
paying for meals even driving them
across state lines to attend meetings
after the verdict governor whitmer's
office demanded accountability calling
the alleged plot the result of violent
divisive rhetoric that is all too common
across our country fox and croft could
face a retrial the other defendants walk
free for cbs saturday morning i'm
adriana diaz